senior foreign affairs correspondent amy
kellogg is in moscow tonight there is no
alternative conclusion other than that
the russian state was culpable for the
attempted murder of mr. scribble and his
daughter this represents an unlawful use
of force by the russian state against
the united kingdom having heard no
credible response from the Russians
about their role in last week's poison
attack British prime minister Theresa
May acted she ordered 23 Russian
diplomats believed to be undeclared
intelligence agents expelled from the
United Kingdom her frustration with
Moscow evident they have treated the use
of a military-grade nerve agent in
Europe with sarcasm contempt and
defiance all high-level meetings between
British and Russian officials are off
for now there will be increased scrutiny
of Russians coming to Britain the
Russians who had demanded a sample of
the nerve agent said mais actions were
an affront I said that everything would
is done today
Russian double agents err Gary Paul and
his daughter Yulia both in a critical
condition were poisoned with a nerve
agent identified by British government
scientists as a nova Chuck a category of
deadly chemical weapons developed in the
Soviet Union to escape detection
despite Russian denials that it
dispatched the agent and the killers
experts say all avenues lead to Russia
the order has to be underwritten by the
top authorities in the Kremlin so this
is a has all the kind of foot prints all
over it
inter-service operation authorized from
the highest level the Kremlin hasn't
taken any action in response to Mays
expulsion but Russian officials say they
are preparing one Russian President
Vladimir Putin may be preoccupied by his
visit to Crimea today where he thanked
residents for voting to rejoin Russia
now Bret the UK called an emergency
session of the UN Security Council this
afternoon the US ambassador nikki Haley
said that America stands by its Ally and
believes that Russia was responsible for
the attack on British soil with a
military-grade chemical weapon we expect
bread also to hear more here in the
Russian capital from the Kremlin in the
coming days brett emma kellogg live in
moscow Amy thank you